I never capitalized the titles of videos
but I had to capitalize this because dr.
strange changes everything in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe okay so so spoiler
free version first alright it's a great
movie um it's it's a lot like guardians
of the galaxy right like the reason why
guardians of the galaxy was so good it
was because it was world building it was
the Marvel Cinematic Universe or I guess
you know Marvel coming and telling us
hey when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's literally a
universe out there and there are all
different kinds of aliens and there's
all different kinds of races and there's
different kinds of places and so on and
so forth we have the Nova Corps we have
Thanos running around you know who's
obsessed with death you know it's a much
bigger world beyond what we saw with
Captain America and Thor and Iron Man
and so on they're just a tiny piece of
the pie dr. strange is very much like
that it's a lot of world building I
liken it to the aspect of age of Ultron
where it was really just you know the
movie had a plot but the purpose of the
movie wasn't the plot the purpose of the
movie was to reveal a tiny bit of
information which would be very
important later on down the line more
notably an age of Ultron it was Thor
when he had the vision of the Infinity
stones the old age of Ultron movie who
was model telling us hey these are the
Infinity stones here's what we know
about them so far and so because of that
you know it was really like a world
building sort of situation dr. strange
is very much like that but the
characters are incredibly good Baron
Mordo is is awesome in this movie he's
he's so good it's it's the way he's
acted out is almost perfect Benedict
Cumberbatch such a good Stephen strange
I was a little hesitant you know about
you know about Barbary cucumber patch
playing the role of dr. strange I wasn't
sure how I would feel about that um I
personally thought that Aidan Gillen I
think his name is that he was going to
be the best person to play Stephen
strange those you guys who don't know
he's the guy that plays a little finger
on Game of Thrones I always felt like he
would have been the perfect Stephen
strange but you know Benedict
Cumberbatch does a great job he does a
perfect job playing that character out
in terms of his arrogance his cockiness
his unwillingness to admit when he's
wrong it's it's perfect you know in
terms of how he plays that role
miel for fertility Swinton I know a lot
of big a lot of discussions were going
on with her character people are asking
you know is it is an insensitive for
Marvel to you have to basically
whitewash the character of the ancient
one I know that was a big talking point
going into it I know there were people
in the audience when I was in a movie
who were asking that question you know
to me it really wasn't that huge of a
deal just because tildes went and played
things so well and that's that's the
great thing about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is that people go into it
expecting a carbon copy of what they've
seen in the comics whether it's
characters their genders their races so
on and so forth wherever they hail from
and so people were going into it they
said well Thor is the same way he was
before when Captain America is the same
way he was before and I am and so on and
so forth why did the ancient one any
different and that's the legitimate
question to ask but I think that with
regards to how she was portrayed in the
movie to heaven that is comic story and
keeping me updated on overwatch but with
regards to you know how she played out
or how she was acted out in the movie
but she did great um she very much had
this sort of tutor you know this mentor
I know a lot of things that you don't
but I'm also hiding something you know
very cloak-and-dagger in terms of how
she acted herself out no that's not a
reference to the characters cloak to
cloak and dagger I wish there was but
but the fact remains that the in terms
of the actors and how they played
everything out it was done well the
movie looked beautiful it looked like
inception meets Fantasia you guys were
those scenes from Inception where
Leonardo DiCaprio was training
what's-her-name the one chick that
turned down the role for for the
PlayStation game and then it turned out
that she should have taken that role in
the first place I can't what her name is
but anyway the scene where they're
having a conversation and he tells her
that you're actually in a dream and she
starts bending the world and different
things like that Doctor Strange is very
much like that you know it's very
similar to that in terms of how it looks
in terms of the weird reality altering
warping kind of events that you see
taking place like what you saw in the
trailers but it's done in a way that
fits it's done in a way where it doesn't
seem out of place because that was one
of my concerns is is this movie going to
feel out of place with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is it going to be so
far in the realm of fantasy that
my Darth Vader poster is it gonna be so
far in the realm of fantasy that is not
gonna make any sense but it works it's
done in a way to where it blends the
kind of real world grounded aspect of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that we've
come to expect with the introduction of
magic into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and they don't shy away from it - that's
the greatest thing because I know
Tiffani over at comic-con
she's a huge Doctor Strange fan you guys
should definitely go over there I'm sure
she's gonna have a lot of stuff on it
but Tiffany with colour-pop she had
talked about how she was afraid that
with Doctor Strange he is a magical
being used the sorcerer of supreme magic
is every ounce a part of his character
as Captain America shield is for Steve
Rogers as the Iron Man suit is for Tony
Stark and Marvel didn't need to shy away
from that and her concern was that they
were going to that they were going to
say well it's not really magic it's like
science no it's magic at no point do you
doubt that it's magic and one of the
greatest things again this isn't really
spoilery but one of the greatest things
is that when Stephen strange is first
when he first encounters a ancient one
she's like we deal with magic here and
he's like that's ridiculous that's crazy
you know this is faith healing you have
no idea what you're talking about it's a
really really cool moment that's that's
what are the cool things - is the jury
that Stephen strange undertakes to
become their sorcerer supreme is
incredibly well done I think it was
better in the comics I'm sorry I don't
think I think it was better than it was
in the comics I think that it was really
better than it was in the animated
feature I think the journey we saw him
take to become the sorcerer supreme is
the best journey that we've seen the
only role the only story with regards to
Stephen strange is origin that I would
say is probably better than this would
be like the oath but that's like the
definitive Doctor Strange story so you
know you really have a hard time
toppling that you know it's like saying
that you have a movie that's better than
the Dark Knight Returns it's not gonna
happen but the fact remains here you
know that the movie in and of itself is
is incredibly well done it's very
entertaining I'm going to see it again
for second time today or I guess tonight
I want to see it last night but I'm
gonna go see it tonight well I guess
this will be Saturday by the time you
guys see this but there's a train
passing by it is it's extremely well
done now for the spoiler stuff now if
you guys don't want to have anything
spoiled for you I'm going to give you to
the count of three one
two three if you're still here you don't
mind having things spoiled for you if
you complain people will laugh at you in
the comment section I invite people to
do that so um do not do that that's bad
do not make fun of people in the
comments that is a rule on my channel
there are consequences for real for true
do not talk down to people in my
comments such and there are consequences
for that um but it all but anyway so
that to back to us having fun back to us
I'm so getting back to us having a good
time there were some major name drops in
this oh my god okay so so we'll get to
the big one what gets us we'll get to
the big one we'll get to the big one but
there's a moment I don't know if it
means anything I pray to God that it
means something but I don't know if it
means anything but there's a scene where
dr. strange is talking to two carrot top
Kalyan Stokes whatever his name is we're
gonna call him carrot he's talking to
carrot and because I can't pronounce
that guy's name right so dr. strange is
talking to carrot you know after he
after he you know temporarily defeats
him and carrot is like obsessed with
Dormammu right you know he's like I'm
gonna go to the Dark Dimension we're
gonna become one with Dormammu we're
gonna let Dormammu take over all things
in existence and dr. strange says no no
that's not how her mom who works because
dr. strange kind of has an idea but
doesn't really know you know and and
carrot this is one of the coolest things
carrot says he's not the devourer of
worlds
he's a devourer of life or something
along those lines devourer of worlds now
the reason why this matters is because
the devourer of worlds is synonymous
with Galactus and Marvel in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has rarely ever ever
ever ever ever referenced the characters
they don't have the rights to it's not
like you had you know the only you had
Tony Stark in Thor and Captain America
and like James Rhodes sitting around it
like yeah with like the four of us are
fantastic it's not like they do anything
like that you know but they literally
say he the devourer of worlds it may not
mean anything but I pray to God it means
that Marvel has a Fantastic Four but I
feel like if my work at the Fantastic
Four writes back the world would know
like every every media company vying for
attention would climb to the
mountaintops and just scream out to
anybody who would listen
Marvel Cinematic Universe has the rights
to the Fantastic Four like that's what I
would do but nonetheless um so a couple
of the things of course the multiverse
is in existence now the multiverse is
something that Marvel in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they've never touched
on not once have they ever referenced
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and that's
a big deal I'm sorry not the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the the multiverse
and that's the big deal because we were
just kind of left to say well maybe this
universe is in and of itself maybe this
universes
you know isolated maybe it's you know
maybe it's part of the multiverse maybe
it's not
we know that Marvel has attributed a
numerical designation to it those are
guys who don't know when it comes to the
multiverse of Marvel Comics and even in
DC comics there's numerical designations
to differentiate between you know one
universe or another for example the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is universe
one nine and then a whole bunch of other
nines and then the main Marvel Universe
in the comics is earth-616 so that's how
they differentiate between you know the
dimensions but the fact remains here
that the multiverse exists and we got to
see a whole bunch of quoted for mostly
verses we got a glimpse of eternity we
got to see what is it what else did we
get to see we got to see the depiction
of one of the dimensions as it was I
think the Dark Dimension as it was drawn
by Jack Kirby and the original Doctor
Strange stories we got to see all kinds
of stuff we got to see some really
really cool things here and there but
when like the when when we first when
when Tilda Swinton when the ancient was
talking to dr. strange and she was like
you know you're just a speck in an
infinitely expanding multiverse
universes that go on forever
my thought was wool I may have run the
multiverse territory then you know what
that means like does that mean what I
think it means yes
yes it does there's a scene hmm yes yeah
there's a scene where dr. strange is
training with Baron Mordo and Baron
Mordo says there are there's power out
there there's magic out there
that is too extreme for us to contain
Omicron them Sultan fanboy just I sound
like a crazy person don't care so there
is a there's a scene where Baron Mordo
who's training dr. strange I hope you
guys are feeling this excitement and he
says there's magic out there there's too
extreme for us to control and so we put
this magic and artifacts because the
artifact can withstand the magic and
then we use the artifacts instead that's
how he explains the wand of look
that's how we get the club of levitation
someone and so forth he pulls out he
pulls out this path and he says he
busted out he's like this is the staff
of the Living Tribunal the Living
Tribunal exists in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe almost like whole wide God now
for those of you guys who don't know I'm
sorry if I'm so excited people for those
of you guys who don't know the Living
Tribunal is second to the one above all
the one above all is this entity that
created all things that existence I mean
it's like the this immutable
indestructible force in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's honest it's for
all intensive purposes God in the Marvel
Universe in the comics but because of
the fact that there are an infinite
number of expanding universes the Living
Tribunal on above all decided there has
to be a custodian there has to be
someone that safeguards these universes
from mystical threats and so it created
the Living Tribunal and the Living
Tribunal exists for the purpose of
making sure that mystical energies don't
go unchecked within a given universe now
it doesn't mean the Living Tribunal will
show up and stop Dormammu from trying to
invade the you know the multiverse but
it said but it basically serves the
purpose of making sure that cosmic
balance doesn't cosmic imbalance doesn't
happen now the reason why this matters
this is why this is why everything is so
connected in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the reason why this matters is
this in 1991 jim Starlin wrote the
Infinity Gauntlet the Infinity Gauntlet
one of the most popular stories ever
written in the history of Marvel Comics
the Infinity Gauntlet of course centers
around Thanos running around and
capturing the Infinity stones like he's
doing in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and guardians of the galaxy we saw the
cocoon of Adam warlock in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline Adam warlock realized
what it was at that house was doing and
basically made this giant call to arms
of everybody who was left after Thanos
wiped out half the life in the universe
by snapping his fingers I can't snap we
gotta snap for me hopefully guys are
snapping for me he wiped out half of
life in the universe by snapping his
fingers and Adam warlock gathered what
was left so it was like some of x-factor
like none of the Fantastic Four some of
the Avengers some of the x-men the
cosmic entities eternity infinity
Galactus Eon Master Order lore chaos
and so forth he gathered the Silver
Surfer he gathered and then and then
like after all after they did all that
they went to the Living Tribunal and
they said hey Thanos is gathering the
Infinity stones can you stop him and the
Libyan tribunal said I could but I'm not
going to and they said why and let me
tribunal said because the cosmic order
the cosmic law as it exists in dr.
strange says that those who were too
weak to continue their their level of
control will be replaced by those who
can ergo if eternity the living
embodiment of the universe is unable to
stand against the power of Thanos and
that also wants to take its place it's
just the cosmic order of things that
Eternity will be destroyed and Thanos
will take his place as you know the
supreme power in that universe and so
because of that you know the Living
Tribunal chose to walk away the tribunal
was able to shut down the Infinity
Gauntlet during the events of infinity
war when that first started off stop
asking yes I will cover that once we get
closer to the Infinity war movie stop
asking so um but during the infinity war
storyline Adam warlock got the Infinity
Gauntlet after Thanos was defeated and
then who started freaking out with all
his power all that kind of stuff like
they put him on trial and like this
comic trial and infinite or eternity was
like he's too crazy to wield the
Infinity Gauntlet and then Adam warlock
was ranting about how powerful he is
and then the Libyan tribunal was like
nope and they just shut down his
Infinity Gauntlet was like you can't use
that anymore because I say so that's how
powerful the letme tribunal is it just
stopped
Adam warlocks ability to use the
Infinity Gauntlet mm-hmm we're talking
about a level of power that's insane but
the Lavi tribunal exists in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's the one thing
to take away from all this The Living
Tribunal exists I'm really I'm very very
excited anyway guys Doctor Strange is an
amazing movie it changes everything and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe it changes
it all we have a multiverse we has a
Living Tribunal we don't know if we have
a wonderf of all yet but I assume we do
we have cosmic entities because we have
a living tribe you know it's it's it
makes a much much bigger picture when
you sit down and think about it like
like go watch my video on the Libby
tribunal all right and then sit down
and think about the Living Tribunal
Thanos gathering the Infinity stones the
Nova Corps all those races that we
introduced in guardians of the galaxy
the superheroes that we have on earth
and you get this massive image of just
how big they're making the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
it's insane anyway guys I'm gonna bring
this to an end if you guys are new here
to come and explain be sure to hit the
sub button become part of the rob Court
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace